Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Without dirt, there could never have been cities or great kings. So claimed the people of Babylon, who knew full well that their civilisation had been fashioned out of mud. Back in the beginning, when all the earth had been ocean, Lord Marduk, king of the gods, had built a raft of reeds, covered it with dust, mingled it with water to form a primordial slime, and out of this raised a home for himself, the Esagila, the first building in the world. And this could still be seen eons later,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。没有泥土，就不会有城市和伟大的君王。巴比伦人深谙此理，他们深知自己的文明正是由泥土塑造而成的。回到最初，当整个世界还是一片汪洋时，众神之王马尔杜克（Lord Marduk）建造了一座芦苇筏，在上面覆满尘土，将其与水混合，化作原始的黏泥，并在此基础上为自己建立了一处居所——埃萨吉拉（Esagila），世界上的第一座建筑。无数岁月之后，人们依然能看到这座建筑，
standing in the heart of Babylon. But it had needed no temple to make the Babylonians appreciate what could be done with earth and water. They knew it in their bones. I will take blood, Marduk had announced in the earliest days of the world, and I will sculpt flesh, and I will form the first man. So that was the former vampire novelist, Tom Holland, dominating the Persian fire fire talking about Babylon. Well when I wrote that I had no idea that Marduk had actually sounded like Winston Churchill but that wasn't Churchill at all that was that was like I will take mud I will take blood I will make humanity. That was the that was the king of the gods what are you talking about?
它静静地矗立在巴比伦的心脏地带。但巴比伦人并不需要一座神庙来领悟泥土与水的造物之力。他们对此有着刻骨铭心的理解。“我将取走鲜血，”马尔杜克曾在世界之初宣告，“我将塑造血肉，我将创造出第一批人类。”刚才那位，正是前吸血鬼小说家汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），他用波斯战火般的语气在谈论巴比伦。好吧，当我写下那些文字时，我根本不知道马尔杜克听起来实际上像是温斯顿·丘吉尔（Winston Churchill），但那根本不是丘吉尔，那听起来像是——“我要取走泥土，我要取走鲜血，我要创造人类。”那可是众神之王啊，你在说什么呢？
So Tom you've wanted to do Babylon since we first talked about doing this podcast, haven't you? Yeah, I really have. To many people, I would say, speaking as a sort of modernist, Babylon is impossibly ancient, unknowable, exotic, confusing. But romantic, don't you think? Yeah, romantic, exactly. Well, romantic, but also it has this kind of sinister edge, doesn't it? Because the word Babylon for centuries in Christianity and afterwards took on this sort of meaning of corruption, I would say, and evil, doesn't it? Because the word Babylon for centuries in Christianity and afterwards took on this sort of meaning of corruption, I would say, and evil, didn't it?
所以，汤姆，自从我们第一次讨论要做这个播客以来，你一直都想做巴比伦的专题，对吧？是的，真的非常想。对许多人来说，以某种现代主义者的视角来看，巴比伦古老得不可思议、无法探知、充满异国情调且令人迷茫。但它很浪漫，你不觉得吗？是的，浪漫，确实如此。嗯，浪漫，但它同时也有一种阴暗的特质，不是吗？因为几个世纪以来，在基督教以及后来的文化中，“巴比伦”这个词逐渐带有一种腐朽的意味，我想说，还有邪恶，不是吗？因为几个世纪以来，在基督教以及后来的文化中，“巴比伦”这个词逐渐带了一种腐朽的意味，我想说，还有邪恶，对吧？
Yes. And it still obviously has that right into the present day with Rastafarianism. I mean, one of the reasons I wanted to do Babylon right from the beginning is that Babylon, in a sense, is the era of the birth of civilization. So Babylonians saw themselves as the heirs of Uruk and Ur and these very, very early cities. Yeah. But I think if you're, so the kind of child I was, obsessed by Greek history and by the Bible, Babylon featured in both. So I would have picture books about Greek history and you'd see portrayals of the Ishtar Gate and the ziggurats and all these kind of incredible monuments. And they would be done in a kind of heroic way.
是的。而且显然直到今天，在拉斯塔法里教（Rastafarianism）中它依然带有这种含义。我的意思是，我从一开始就想做巴比伦的原因之一，是因为从某种意义上说，巴比伦是文明诞生的时代。因此，巴比伦人视自己为乌鲁克（Uruk）、乌尔（Ur）以及这些非常非常古老的城市的继承者。是的。但我想，如果你和我一样，是那种从小痴迷于希腊历史和《圣经》的孩子，巴比伦在这两方面都有着重要的地位。所以我会有关于希腊历史的绘本，你会在其中看到对伊什塔尔门（Ishtar Gate）和塔庙（ziggurats）以及所有这些不可思议的纪念碑的描绘。它们会被赋予一种英雄主义的色彩。
You'd be expected to kind of admire the dazzle and the splendor of it. And then there'd be an illustrated Bible and you'd have, you know, the Judeans weeping by the rivers of Babylon. And there it would be sinister. And I think it's that mix of the glamorous and the sinister that right from my childhood has kind of haunted me. And so that's why, you know, you read that very purple passage of prose. I find it very difficult to even think about uh babylon and not kind of lurch into into the fake a vague hint of purple so uh so that's something's no need to you sound like you're making excuses now which is no i'm not i'm not because i think that that sense is actually bred of the city itself because um the city had a kind of consciousness of itself as being the center of the world itself because the city had a kind of consciousness of itself
你会情不自禁地去惊叹它的耀眼与辉煌。然后又会有带插图的《圣经》，你会看到犹太人在巴比伦河畔哭泣。在那里，它又是阴暗的。我认为正是这种迷人与阴暗的交织，从我的童年起就一直萦绕在我的心头。所以这就是为什么，你知道，你会读到那段非常华丽浮夸的散文。我甚至发现，只要一想到巴比伦，我就很难不陷入那种虚假而模糊的浮夸语调中。所以——没必要，听起来你现在是在为自己找借口，这——不，我不是，我真的不是，因为我认为这种感觉其实正是孕育自这座城市本身；因为……这座城市自身就有一种作为世界中心的意识，因为这座城市自身就有一种意识，
as being the center of the world. The Babylonians would approve of your prose is what you're saying. I think they would. I think they would appreciate it. And I think they would absolutely, they'd probably be offended that it's taken us this long to do an episode on that. So Babylon is impossibly old. And I think what we should do is, well, I think we both think we will come back to the
即它是世界的中心。巴比伦人会赞同你的散文，这就是你想表达的。我想他们会的。我想他们会欣赏的。而且我认为他们绝对会——他们可能会对我们花了这么长时间才做一期关于他们的节目感到被冒犯。所以，巴比伦古老得不可思议。我想我们接下来应该做的，嗯，我想我们两个都觉得我们会在另一期节目中回过头来探讨
early, the really early stuff in another episode. But let's concentrate now on the most famous period of Babylonian history, the most colorful, the most well-chronicled. And that's the period from Nebuchadnezzar onwards. So Babylon at that point is about, what, more than 1,000 years old? Yes, probably founded around 1900 BC. And the Esagila, which was mentioned in the Magnificent opening that you read. Magnificent. That seems to date back to about that time. So in that sense, the roots of Babylon are very venerable.
早期，那些真正早期的内容。但现在让我们专注于巴比伦历史上最著名、最色彩斑斓、最被详细记录的时期。也就是从尼布甲尼撒（Nebuchadnezzar）开始的时期。所以当时的巴比伦大概有多少岁了，一千多岁？是的，大概建于公元前1900年左右。而你刚才在宏伟的开场中读到的埃萨吉拉神庙——宏伟。它似乎可以追溯到那个时期左右。从这个意义上说，巴比伦的根基非常悠久。
But there's a complication, which is that Babylon, for a long period, has had this terrifying neighbor called Assyria. And if you imagine Mesopotamia as a kind of a bottle, Assyria is like the kind of angry hornet trapped inside the bottle. And at one point, an Assyrian king, Sennacherib, had actually flattened Babylon completely, presumably wiping out the Esagila as well. So the great city that you shut your eyes, you imagine the blue and gold bricks, the incredible monuments, all that kind of stuff, this has rebuilt um on the kind of models that pre-existed but but relatively speaking babylon in that sense is both a very ancient and quite a modern city and as you say the person who is responsible for this great process of construction um is nebuchadnezzar and just for
但这里有一个复杂的情况，那就是长期以来，巴比伦一直有一个可怕的邻居叫亚述（Assyria）。如果你把美索不达米亚（Mesopotamia）想象成一个瓶子，亚述就像是被困在瓶子里的一只愤怒的大黄蜂。有一次，亚述国王西拿基立（Sennacherib）甚至彻底夷平了巴比伦，想必连埃萨吉拉神庙也被摧毁了。所以这座当你闭上眼睛、脑海中浮现出的蓝色和金色砖块、不可思议的纪念碑以及所有这些东西的伟大城市，是在以前的模式基础之上重建的。但相对而言，从这个意义上说，巴比伦既是一座非常古老的城市，也是一座相当现代的城市。正如你所说，负责这项伟大建设工程的人是尼布甲尼撒。为了
those people who don't know so babylon is in modern-day iraq it's south of baghdad yeah on the banks of the euphrates so it's in this sort of cradle of civilization mesopotamia between the two rivers yes the other river being the yeah and it's got a thousand year old more than a thousand and they're very conscious their own history aren't they their own heritage and stuff yeah well they they um they come to think of babylon as being kind of the very earliest city. They see Babylon as a gift from the kind of the junior gods to the senior gods. I mean, actually, they also, confusingly at the same time, are aware that there are other cities that are actually much older than Babylon.
那些不太了解的人说明一下：巴比伦位于今天的伊拉克，在巴格达以南，是的，位于幼发拉底河（Euphrates）畔。所以它位于美索不达米亚这个文明的摇篮里，夹在两条河之间。是的，另一条河是——是的，它有一千多年的历史，甚至更久。他们对自己的历史和文化遗产有着非常清醒的认知，对吧？是的，他们……他们开始将巴比伦视为最早的城市。他们视巴比伦为次要神祇送给主要神祇的礼物。我的意思是，实际上，令人困惑的是，他们在同一时期也意识到还有其他城市其实比巴比伦更古老。
And so they have this kind of dual sense of time. But basically, everyone in Mesopotamia by this point sees Babylon as the kind of the great fulcrum of the world. It's the centre of the world. It's the centre of time. It's the great home of culture. And that's as true for the Assyrians as it is for the Babylonians themselves. So that's the key to its status. They've been occupied lots of times and attacked lots of times by different rising and falling, the Hittites, hittites the cassites all these different all these kind of guys yeah all these guys who keep evading they steal the god marduk um who we mentioned in the introduction they take him off to their city and then inevitably he always comes back at some stage yeah and babylon then rises again that's basically the story of the last 1400 years of babylonian, isn't it? Yeah, so basically the prehistory of Babylon
因此他们有一种双重的时间观念。但基本上，到这个时候，美索不达米亚的每个人都将巴比伦视为世界的伟大枢纽。它是世界的中心。它是时间的中心。它是伟大的文化发源地。对于亚述人来说如此，对于巴比伦人自己来说也是如此。这就是它地位的关键所在。他们曾多次被占领，也多次遭到不同崛起和衰落的势力的攻击，比如赫梯人（Hittites）、加喜特人（Kassites）以及所有这些不同的人，所有这些家伙——是的，所有这些不断入侵的家伙，他们会偷走我们在引言中提到过的神明马尔杜克，把他带到他们自己的城市，然后不可避免地，他在某个阶段总是会回来，是的，接着巴比伦就会再次崛起。这基本上就是巴比伦过去1400年历史的写照，不是吗？是的，所以基本上，尼布甲尼撒统治之前的
prior to the reign of Nebuchadnezzar is a series of people with strange names turning up at Babylon, nicking the statue of Marduk and the Babylonians and getting it back. All right, very good. So I think what we should do is we'll come back to that and do that in real detail in a future episode.
巴比伦史前史，就是一群名字奇怪的人来到巴比伦，偷走马尔杜克的雕像，然后巴比伦人再把它夺回来。好吧，非常好。所以我觉得我们应该做的是，以后再回过头来，在未来的节目中详细探讨这一点。
But let's get back in with nebuchadnezzar so what century roughly are we in now tom we are in the sixth century bc sixth century so we are roughly equivalent with what um with with with the first that we know of the ancient greeks i guess yes so um yeah so so this is um ath Athens and Sparta are starting to emerge as major powers in Greece. It's the early years of Rome. And of course, you know, very importantly, there is, you know, the Persians are kind of gearing up. They're still subordinate to the Medes at this time, Babylon is greater, richer, presumably more sophisticated, more kind of politically important than any of these places. Well, whether it's politically more important, whether it's the greatest of power will be measured by what happens to it at the end of the century. But indisputably, it is the greatest city, not just of its age, but of all time.
但让我们回到尼布甲尼撒上来。汤姆，我们现在大概处于哪个世纪？我们正处于公元前六世纪。公元前六世纪。所以我们大致相当于——嗯，与我们所知的古希腊早期相对应，我猜？是的。所以，嗯，是的，所以这是——雅典和斯巴达开始作为希腊的主要强权崛起。这是罗马的早期。当然，非常重要的是，波斯人正在蓄势待发。此时他们仍然臣服于米底人（Medes）。巴比伦比所有这些地方都要宏大、富有，想必也更成熟、在政治上更重要。至于它在政治上是否更重要、是否是最伟大的强权，将由它在本世纪末的遭遇来衡量。但毫无疑问，它不仅是那个时代最伟大的城市，而且是有史以来最伟大的城市。
There has never been a larger city. So there are about quarter of a million people in the city um and this is what the babylon of nebuchadnezzar absolutely is and so nebuchadnezzar succeeds his father when tom uh when does he succeed that's a good question 605 yes yeah so there's a battle with the egyptians in syria so the egyptians are also trying to make a comeback at this point um the the babylonians defeat the egyptians nabopolassar dies in the battle nebuchadnezzar takes over uh and the assyrian the egyptians retreat and it is this that opens up not just syria but the kingdom of judah okay let's come on to judah in a second
从来没有过比这更大的城市。城里大约有二十五万人口，这绝对就是尼布甲尼撒的巴比伦。那么，汤姆，尼布甲尼撒是什么时候继承他父亲的王位的？这是一个好问题，公元前605年，是的。所以在叙利亚与埃及人有一场战役，因为埃及人此时也试图东山再起。巴比伦人击败了埃及人，那波帕拉萨尔（Nabopolassar）在战役中去世，尼布甲尼撒接管了权力，埃及人撤退了。正是这一事件，不仅打开了叙利亚的大门，也打开了犹大王国（kingdom of Judah）的大门。好了，我们一会儿再来谈犹大，
because that will bring us into the bible which which I want to talk about. But first, you mentioned the city. So the city of Nebuchadnezzar. So now we can, perhaps for the first time, really get into what Babylon is like, because we know, don't we? We have descriptions of Nebuchadnezzar's Babylon, and we have a sort of sense of the topography. Is that right? We do. So we have an account by Herodotus who almost certainly visited it. And as is normally the case with Herodotus, it's a kind of mix of kind of imaginary, you know, he's projecting Greek ideas about society. Don't tell me the founder of history is making stuff up, Tom. He's not making it up.
因为那将把我们带入《圣经》，这也是我想谈论的。但首先，你提到了城市。也就是尼布甲尼撒的城市。所以现在，也许是第一次，我们可以真正了解巴比伦是什么样子的了，因为我们知道，对吧？我们有关于尼布甲尼撒巴比伦的描述，我们对它的地形也有了一定的了解。是这样吗？是的。所以我们有希罗多德（Herodotus）的记述，他几乎可以肯定是亲自访问过这里的。正如希罗多德的一贯作风，这其中夹杂着某种虚构成分——你知道的，他把希腊人对社会的观念投射到了那里。别告诉我历史之父在胡编乱造，汤姆。他没有胡编乱造。
Well, so the classic example of this is talking about marriage and the role of women in Babylon. And he cites two customs, one of which is that daughters get auctioned off and all the good-looking daughters get auctioned off first. And the money that is given for their dowries then enables the uglier daughters to be married as well and to be given dowries and Herodotus really approves of this he says it's a wonderful custom absolutely thumbs up from Herodotus for that um but then there is the custom that he describes as the most outrageous of the Babylonian customs and this is that every woman in the city he says has to go to the temple and offer herself up for money for sex to anyone who wants her. And they have no choice in the matter.
好吧，最典型的例子就是他谈到巴比伦的婚姻和女性的角色。他列举了两种习俗，其中之一是女儿们会被拿出来拍卖，长得漂亮的女儿首先被拍卖。为她们支付的嫁妆钱随后又能让长相较丑的女儿们也嫁出去，并获得嫁妆。希罗多德对这个习俗非常赞赏，他说这是一个美妙的习俗。希罗多德绝对给这个习俗竖起了大拇指。但接着，他又描述了另一个被他称为巴比伦最令人发指的习俗：他说，城里的每个女性都必须前往神庙，为了金钱而向任何想要她的人出卖肉体以换取性服务。而且她们对此别无选择。
Everybody has to do this. Everybody. So even the kind of very grandest woman and Herodotus says that they arrive in litters and veils so that no one can see them. And then someone will come in and sleep with them and then they go off and then that's it. Their due is paid. So there is this debate as to whether how how reliable is this it seems so it seems to draw on what is a very ancient tradition of that the princesses dedicate themselves to a god called shamash who's the sun god
每个人都必须这么做。所有人。所以即使是最高贵的女性，希罗多德也说她们会乘着轿子、戴着面纱到达，这样就没有人能认出她们。然后会有人进来与她们同房，随后她们便离去，这样就算完成了她们的职责。因此，这里存在一个争论：这些记载究竟有多高的可靠性？它似乎——它似乎借鉴了一个非常古老的传统，即公主们把自己献给一个名叫沙马什（Shamash）的神，也就是太阳神。
and there's evidence for this going right the way back to the very beginnings of babylon um but they're actually they certainly in the time of back of the time of ham rabbi these women seem more like nuns than kind of temple prostitutes yeah um they basically seem to have lived under an obligation of celibacy um they uh they and actually they're kind of quite economically significant players there could be some annual ritual you know there could be couldn't there could be there could be some annual ritual, you know. There could be. Couldn't there? There could be. There could be. So that's, and we'll come again to this, the extent to which Herodotus and other classical
有证据表明，这一传统可以一直追溯到巴比伦的最早期。但实际上——至少在汉谟拉比（Hammurabi）的时代，这些女性看起来更像是修女，而不是某种庙妓。是的，她们基本上似乎是在遵守独身义务的约束下生活的。她们——而且实际上她们在经济上是相当重要的参与者。可能会有一些年度仪式，你知道的，可能会有——难道不是吗？可能会有某种年度仪式，你知道的。可能会有。难道不是吗？可能会有。可能会有。所以这就是——我们以后还会谈到这一点——希罗多德和其他古典作家在多大程度上是在凭空捏造，或者他们是否只是误解了他们所看到的东西。毫无疑问，希罗多德有许多非常非常详细的事实分析，后来证明都非常准确。因此，这与考古学结合起来，让我们对尼布甲尼撒的城市面貌有了一个大致的了解。好吧，等等。假设你就是希罗多德或其他什么人，你第一次走近巴比伦。所以你是穿过平坦、平坦的冲积平原走近它的。是的。在
authors are just making stuff up from scratch, whether they're misunderstanding things that they see. And definitely with Herodotus, there's a lot of very, very detailed factual analysis that has turned out to be very accurate. And so that combined with the archaeology gives us a sense of probably of what Nebuchadnezzar's city looked like. Okay, well, stop. Let's imagine you're Herodotus or whoever, you're approaching Babylon for the first time. So you're approaching it across flat, flat, alluvial lands. Yeah. And the banks of the
幼发拉底河畔，你在热浪迷蒙中看到远处的景象，我想，你首先看到的将是巨大的城墙。是的。所以这些城墙堪称奇迹。世界七大奇迹，“七”对巴比伦人来说是神圣的。所以这种被希腊人采纳并被古典作家反复提及的观念，最初可能就是一个美索不达米亚的概念。在其中一份世界奇迹的名单中，巴比伦城墙便赫然在列。亚述人曾盛赞它们为世界奇迹。它们的规模大得惊人。它们绵延三平方英里。周围环绕着护城河。还有更多的城墙。有一道由尼布甲尼撒修建的被称为“米底墙”（Median Wall）的城墙，旨在将米底人拒之门外，全长达50英里。
Euphrates, you see in the distance through the heat haze, the first thing you see, I imagine, is the enormous city walls. Yes. So the walls are wonders. So the seven wonders of the world, the seven is sacred to the Babylonians. So it's possible that this idea, which gets picked up by the Greeks and then recycled by classical writers, that this is originally a Mesopotamian idea. And one of the wonders of the world in one of the lists, the walls of Babylon feature. And the Assyrians had hailed them as a wonder of the world. They are on a stupefying scale. They extend for three square miles. They're surrounded by moats. And there are further walls. There's a wall that's built by Nebuchadnezzar called the Median Wall, which is designed to keep the Medes out, which goes for 50 miles.
所以这些是庞大无比的防御工事。它们成为了君主制所代表的一切事物的某种象征。所以它们是——嗯，尼布甲尼撒有一块铭文，他在其中将巴比伦城墙描述为“自远古以来便闻名遐迩的原始边界，与时间一样古老的坚固前沿，高耸入云的高地，阻挡敌国入侵的坚固盾牌”。嗯，事实上，它并非原始的，因为它们不断遭到洗劫，也不断需要重建。但巴比伦城墙作为某种奇观的概念确实非常非常古老。希罗多德对它们惊叹不已，他描述了——
So these are vast, vast fortifications. And they serve as a kind of symbol of everything that the monarchy is about. So they are, well, there's an inscription by Nebuchadnezzar who says, he describes the wall of Babylon as the primeval boundary that has been famous since the distant past, the firm frontier as old as time, the lofty area as high as the heavens, the strong shield that bars access from enemy lands. I mean, in truth, it's not primeval because they keep being sacked and keep having to be rebuilt. But the idea of the wall of Babylon as a kind of wonder really is very, very ancient. And Herodotus is blown away by them. And he describes-
它们是蓝色的吗，汤姆？它们是蓝色的吗？嗯，我们一会儿会谈到这一点。它们有雉堞。所以它们的规模极其宏大。希罗多德说，它们宽得足以让一辆战车在上面掉头。但你也会看到那座著名的城门——
They're blue, Tom? Are they blue? Well, we'll come to that. They're crenellated. So they're on a massive scale. They're so broad, Herodotus says, that a chariot can wheel around on the top. But you also get this famous gate,
伊什塔尔门，在尼布甲尼撒统治时期，它拥有那种著名的蓝金相间的瓷砖。这些是泥砖，但外面包裹着蓝色的和金色的饰面。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为德国考古学家发现了它们，并将它们运走带到了柏林，在那里你可以看到这种令人难以置信的复原品。这是一座宏伟的双重城门。伊什塔尔门通往巴比伦人所称的“莫使狂妄者昌盛”的大道，这是一条宏伟的游行大道。你穿过城门，就会看到王宫，对于巴比伦国王来说，这自然是符合身份的、令人目眩神迷的王宫。
the Ishtar Gate, which under Nebuchadnezzar has the kind of the famous blue and gold tiles. These are mud bricks, but they're sheathed in blue and gold. And we know about that because German archaeologists discovered them and shipped them up and took them to Berlin, where you can see this kind of incredible reproduction of it. And it's a great double gate. And the Ishtar Gate leads into what the Babylonians called May the Arrogant Not Flourish, which was this great processional way. And you go in through the gate and there you have the palace, which is fittingly stupefying for the king of Babylon.
一切都如你所料。哇。然后你沿着游行大道走下去，在游行大道的尽头，你会看到被称为“埃特曼安奇”（Etemenanki）的建筑，这是一座大得令人瞠目结舌的巨大塔庙，拥有1700万块砖，高100米——和吉萨大金字塔一样高，有七层楼高，不过希罗多德说有八层。这就是那座曾被亚述人洗劫、被亚述国王西拿基立摧毁，并此后不断被重建的建筑。这座宏伟高塔的建造，在《圣经》中就演变成了巴别塔（Tower of Babel）。所以这就是巴别塔。我的意思是，字面意义上的巴别塔。
Everything you'd expect. Wow. And then you go down the processional way at the far end of the processional way you have what was called the um the etem ananki which is the stupefyingly enormous uh ziggurat 17 million bricks 100 meters high so as high as the great pyramid uh seven stories although herodotus says it's eight um and this is this is the building that that had been sacked by the Assyrians, destroyed by Sennacherib, the Assyrian king, and has been rebuilt ever since. And this is the construction of this great tower is what in the Bible becomes the Tower of Babel. So this is the Tower of Babel. I mean, literally the Tower of Babel.
想必——好吧，关于它的某些记忆进入了《圣经》的《旧约》中，对吧？想必是因为它是被沦为奴隶的人建造的，人们对被奴役并在这种建筑上劳作有着一种集体记忆？我不认为那是——不，我不认为那是它的重点。所以在《创世记》中，重点是建造它的人们的狂妄自大，对吧？然后上帝惩罚了他们。但你知道，塔并没有建成。他们开始说不同的语言。因此，也就有了“巴别”（Babel）这个词。所以它本质上是关于建造者们的狂妄自大。
And presumably, okay, so some memory of it has made it into the bible into the old testament yeah presumably is that because it was built by slaves who have and a folk memory of people being enslaved and having to work on this building i don't think that's no i don't think that's the focus of it in so in the in genesis it's it's about the arrogance of the people who are building it right and god punishes them but know, the tower isn't finished. They will start speaking different languages. So hence, you know, a Babel. So it's essentially about the arrogance of the people who are building it.
而这一点，你知道的，我们稍后会谈到犹太人是如何融入其中的。但本质上，犹太人、犹太族对巴比伦的每一个看法都是：它是一个压迫者。它极其富有。它充满了黄金。它充满了紫色。但由于它的狂妄自大，它注定要灭亡。既残酷又暴虐。没错，正是如此。所以这就是——而且我确信，关于巴别塔的记忆之所以存在，是因为当犹太流亡者到达那里并看到这座仍在建设中的塔庙时，我们一会儿就会
And that, you know, will come to how the Jews fit into this. But essentially, every take that the Judeans, the Jews have on Babylon is that it is an oppressor. It's spectacularly rich. It's full of gold. It's full of purple. But it is doomed due to its arrogance. Kind of cruel and tyrannical. Yeah, exactly. And so that's what the... And I'm sure that the memory of the Tower of babel is because this ziggurat was still in the process of being completed when the judean exiles arrived there and see it which we'll
谈到这一点。还有一件事，巴比伦不仅是一座权力之城，它也是一座享乐之城，“这座城市的人民沉溺于财富，这座城市充满了庆典、欢庆和无休止的舞蹈”。这——这又是你的浮夸散文吗？不，那是当时的铭文。它反映了这样一个事实：巴比伦同时也是一座非常有秩序的城市。这里有一种网格状的布局，但在这些网格之内，又有着各种迷宫。所以你完全会在里面迷路。这就是它作为享乐之城的名声的由来，这种名声在《圣经》的推波助澜下得以传播，同时也源于希罗多德关于庙妓的故事——在《圣经》的推波助澜下得以传播，同时也源于希罗多德关于庙妓的故事等等。
come to in a second just another thing babylon's not just a city of power but it's also a city of pleasure uh the city whose people are glutted with wealth the city of celebrations rejoicing and endless dance is that that is that your purple prose again? No, that's an inscription of the time. And it reflects the fact that Babylon is simultaneously a very ordered city. So there's a kind of grid pattern, but within those grids, there are kind of labyrinths. So you can completely get lost. And that's where its reputation as a city of pleasure comes from, kind of fueled by the Bible, but also by Herodotus' story of temple prostitutes and by the bible but also by the herodotus's story of temple prostitutes and so on and also by the image of the goddess ishtar who gives her name
还有女神伊什塔尔（Ishtar）的形象，著名的城门就是以她的名字命名的。她是掌管爱情的女神，被想象成是在酒馆里徘徊遊荡。所以，如果你穿过平原，走过城门，你就会一头扎进这个令人难以置信的、想必极其国际化、难以想象地国际化的世界。这里有各种景象、气味和不同的语言，诸如此类。是的，这里是世界上绝对最大的城市。它是地球上存在过的最大的城市，它是最具国际大都市气息的，它富得流产，而且它极其成熟，因为你开始看到银行的出现。
to the the famous gate who is the goddess of love who is imagined as as stalking the the taverns so if you have come in across the plain you've gone through the gates you're plunged into this incredible presumably incredibly cosmopolitan unbelievably cosmopolitan it is sights and smells and different languages and yeah all this kind of stuff yeah the biggest city in the world by miles it's the largest city that's ever existed on the planet it's the most cosmopolitan it's it's stupefyingly rich uh and it's it's incredibly sophisticated because you're starting to get banks so we have that there's a record a banking family called the agibis whose library has been found you know record of all their
我们有记录显示，有一个名叫埃吉比（Egibi）的银行家族，他们的图书馆已经被发现了，你知道的，里面记录了他们所有的通信和一切。这表明巴比伦帝国的规模足够大，以至于这个在巴比伦的银行家族可以在其他城市拥有分支机构。这就是为什么巴比伦可以成为一个庞大的、多元文化的、大都市的、帝国的、富裕的城市的代名词，在这里你可以从事各种在村庄里可能无法进行的性行为。你知道，巴比伦就是这种现象的原型。这就是它的神话力量所在。
correspondence and everything and it it shows how the the babylonian empire is sufficiently large that this banking family in babylon can have kind of outposts in in other cities um And it's the reason why Babylon works as a kind of, you know, a shorthand for a massive, multicultural, cosmopolitan, imperial, wealthy city where you can get up to all kinds of sexual practices that maybe you couldn't in a village. You know, Babylon is the archetype of that. And that's the power of its myth. So do you think it's the first city to have that kind of reputation as the kind of by the sink of iniquity and a place of unlimited possibility? Well, it's difficult to know, but the combination of the Greek and the biblical accounts of it are essentially what have created that image of it that has survived. They're able to do that because babylon has elements of that yeah i mean it is it is an absolutely stupefying place and it is
所以你认为它是第一座拥有这种“罪恶渊薮”和“无限可能之地”声誉的城市吗？嗯，这很难说，但希腊和《圣经》对它的描述结合在一起，基本上塑造了流传至今的关于它的那种形象。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为巴比伦确实具备这些元素。是的，我的意思是，它绝对是一个令人目眩神迷的地方，而且它实际上是——你知道的，在世界奇迹的名单中，它是唯一一个肯定有两个奇迹、甚至可能三个奇迹的地方。所以有一个著名的方尖碑，它被收录在其中一些奇迹的名单中——世界七大奇迹。城墙出现在许多关于世界奇迹的名单中。当然，它是最著名的奇迹。事实上，昨天我问我的妻子萨迪（Sadie），当你想到巴比伦时，你首先会想到什么？她说，空中花园（Hanging Gardens）。
actually the you know in the list of the wonders of the world it's the only one that has certainly two wonders maybe even three so there's a there's a kind of there's a famous obelisk that gets into some of the wonders of that list the seven wonders of the world the the walls feature in a lot of the lists of the wonders of the world and of course seven wonders of the world. The walls feature in a lot of the lists of the wonders of the world. And of course, it's the most famous wonder of all. In fact, yesterday I asked Sadie, my wife, what do you think of when you think of Babylon? And she said, the hanging gardens.
当然。所以空中花园是巴比伦所有奇迹中最神秘、最撩人心弦的一个。但是希罗多德——你刚才说他访问过巴比伦——甚至都没有提到它们。他根本没有提到它们。那么关于空中花园，人们是怎么想的呢？嗯，希罗多德没有提到它们。如果他真的访问过巴比伦（我认为他确实去过），那大概是在巴比伦陷落并被波斯人征服大约100年之后。也许他没有看到它们，因为花园位于某种宫殿建筑群内部，所以你根本看不到。但至今没有任何关于它们的考古证据。
Of course. So the hanging gardens are the most enigmatic and the most kind of tantalizing of all the wonders of Babylon. But Herodotus, who you say went to Babylon, doesn't even mention them. He doesn't mention them. So what's the thinking with the hanging gardens? Well, Herodotus doesn't mention them. If he visited Babylon, which I think he did, that would be about 100 years after its fall and its conquest by the Persians. Maybe he didn't see them because the gardens are in a kind of palace complex, so you don't get to see them. But there's been no archaeological evidence for them at all.
因此，牛津大学的斯蒂芬妮·戴利（Stephanie Daly）写了一本非常非常有趣的书。她认为，事实上，巴比伦的空中花园根本不在巴比伦。这个故事是——我们从公元一世纪写作的约瑟夫斯（Josephus）那里得知这一点——他说正是尼布甲尼撒建造了这些花园。故事的内容是，他娶了一位米底妻子，她对故乡的山峦非常思念。于是尼布甲尼撒建造了这样一座宏伟的建筑群。
And so there's been a very, very interesting book written by Stephanie Daly, who I think is at Oxford, who argues that actually the hanged gardens of Babylon were not in Babylon at all. The story is that, and we get this from Josephus, who is writing in the first century AD. He said he says that it's Nebuchadnezzar who builds these gardens. And the story is, is that he has a median wife and that she's homesick for the mountains of her homeland. And so Nebuchadnezzar builds this great kind of complex.
关于这个建筑群，最奇妙的是它是阶梯状建造的。所以你可以想象一下，有点像希腊剧场或类似的东西，一层一层向上递进。在这些梯田的最高层种植着树木，这些树木必须依靠水来滋养。它们必须有水灌溉，否则它们的根系无法深入土壤。你知道，它们种在某种花坛里。但没有证据表明这一点。没有在巴比伦发现过这样的结构。巴比伦也没有描绘过这样的结构。
And the thing about it is that it's done on kind of steps. So imagine a bit like the kind of Greek theater or something like that going up in stages. And that there are trees that are planted on the highest level of these tiers that are being fed by water. They must be fed by water because otherwise they can't reach into the soil. You know, they're in kind of flower beds. And there's no evidence for this. No such structure has been found. No such structure has been portrayed in Babylon.
我的意思是，在巴比伦要做到这一点将是非常非常困难的。但你在亚述的壁画中确实能看到对这种结构的描绘，而且你似乎也能找到相关的证据。尤其是那种后来被归功于阿基米德（Archimedes）的螺旋水泵，有证据表明那是古代亚述人发明的。你是在说，最具有讽刺意味的是，亚述人——偏偏是亚述人和巴比伦人——最著名的巴比伦事物实际上是亚述的？嗯，我完全没有资格去评判这个论点是否准确。我的意思是，我读过斯蒂芬妮·戴利的书。我读了两遍。我在做这个播客之前读过。后来我又重读了一遍。我完全被说服了，但那是因为我其实没有足够的知识去做出评判。
I mean, it would be very, very difficult to do that in Babylon. But you do have portraits of this in Assyrian wall paintings, and you do seem to have kind of evidence for it. And in particular, you have the kind of screw that gets attributed much later to Archimedes, that there's evidence for that having been developed by the Assyrians. The irony that the Assyrians of all people, the Babylonians, that the most famous Babylonian thing was probably Assyrian, you're saying? Well, I'm not remotely qualified to judge on whether this argument is accurate or not. I mean, I read Stephanie Daly's book. I've read it twice. I read it before doing this podcast. Again, I reread it. I'm completely convinced, but that's because I don't really know enough to judge.
不过，我的意思是，不仅仅是亚述人，西拿基立正是那个夷平了巴比伦的人，这可以说是真正在伤口上撒盐。她的观点是，当西拿基立摧毁巴比伦时，他说，好吧，现在尼尼微（Nineveh）就是巴比伦。是的，你可以看出这会是如何运作的。而且我们有很多——所以希罗多德理所当然地认为巴比伦是亚述的一部分，亚述人和巴比伦人基本上是同一个人。你有一位名叫狄奥多罗斯（Diodorus）的历史学家，生活在大约公元二世纪，他说建造空中花园的国王是亚述人。换句话说，这里存在着各种可能性的漩涡。
But I mean, it's not just the Assyrians, it senecrib who's the guy who who flattened babylon so kind of really rubbing salt in the wounds um and her argument is that when senecrib destroys babylon he says well nineveh is now babylon yes you could see how um how that would work and we there's a lot so herodotus is absolutely he takes for granted that um that babylon is a part of assyria and the assyrians and babylonians are basically the same people you have a historian called diodorus who's writing um i think second century who says that um the king who who built the hanging gardens was assyrian so in other words there's a swirl of yeah possibilities there um and. And it's also possible
而且，尼尼微从大地上被抹去的传统也并非完全如此。这似乎并未发生。确实似乎存在着宫殿建筑群，因为我们知道后来的国王会前往尼尼微并对其进行研究，将其作为如何仿建自己宫殿的范例等等。所以谁知道呢？但我认为这是一个非常非常好的论点：实际上，那不是巴比伦的空中花园，而是尼尼微的空中花园。好吧，这就回答了西蒙·格德尔斯通（Simon Girdlestone）和迪克·阿克斯（Dick of Axe）提出的问题，他们两个人都问到了空中花园。
that Nineveh was, so the tradition is that Nineveh is white from the face of the earth. This doesn't seem to have happened. It does seem that there were palace complexes because we know that later kings are going to Nineveh and kind of studying it, you know, for examples of how they can kind of model their own palaces and so on so who knows but but i think it's a very very good argument that actually it's not the hanging gardens of babylon it's the hanging gardens of nineveh well that's answered the questions by simon girdlestone and dick of axe both who asked about their hanging gardens um dick of axe's question though raises another issue that hangs over the whole discussion of of babylon because dick of axe wanted to know whether the
不过，迪克·阿克斯的问题引发了另一个笼罩在整个巴比伦讨论之上的问题，因为迪克·阿克斯想知道巴比伦的花园是否在某种程度上与对伊甸园（Garden of Eden）的描述有关。他说，巴比伦与《旧约》之间有什么联系？现在，显然这是一个巨大的话题。所以，犹太人对巴比伦以及尼布甲尼撒的描绘——伯沙撒的盛宴（Belshazzar's feast）、《但以理书》（Book of Daniel）。让我们现在就深入探讨这一切。那么，为什么会有犹太人在巴比伦呢？好吧，首先，我们应该称他们为犹太人吗？在这个时期可能不应该。以色列人？不，他们是犹大王国的人。所以他们曾在达味（David）和所罗门（Solomon）等人的统治下组成联合王国。然后它分裂了。你有了北国以色列，
gardens of babylon were linked in some way to know whether the gardens of Babylon were linked in some way to descriptions of the Garden of Eden. And he said, what are the links between Babylon and the Old Testament? Now, obviously, this is a massive issue. So the Jews, the portrait of Babylon and indeed of Nebuchadnezzar, Belshazzar's feast, the book of Daniel. Let's get into all that now. So why are there Jews in Babylon? Okay, well, first of all, should we be calling them Jews? Probably not at this point. Israelites? No, they're the people of the kingdom of Judah. So they'd been the United Monarchy under David and Solomon and so on. Then it is split. You'd get the northern kingdom of Israel,
以色列有12个支派。其中的10个支派组成了北国以色列——以色列有12个支派。其中的10个支派组成了以色列王国，后来被亚述人摧毁。这10个支派被亚述人驱逐流放，从此销声匿迹。所以这10个支派在哪里，一直是一个不解之谜。以耶路撒冷城为中心的另外两个支派存活了下来。这就是犹大王国。与埃及、亚述或巴比伦相比，它只是一个小不点。这些伟大的帝国不断出现，在犹大诸王的脸上踢沙子，所以他们不断地试图弄清楚——你知道的，我们究竟该站在埃及人一边，还是亚述人一边，还是巴比伦人一边？无论如何，尼布甲尼撒——他击退了亚述人，巴比伦人击退了亚述人，他们击退了亚述人，他们击退了埃及人。公元前597年，耶路撒冷被征服。国王和一大批犹大贵族被带走。这就是约雅斤（Jehoiachin）。我没说错吧？正是如此。
10 tribes of, so there are 12 tribes of Israel. 10 of those tribes form northern kingdom of Israel, 10 tribes of, so there are 12 tribes of Yibreel. 10 of those tribes form the kingdom of Israel that then gets destroyed by the Assyrians. And the 10 tribes get carted off into exile by the Assyrians and they vanish. So the question of where the 10 tribes are, it's kind of abiding mystery. Two of the tribes centered on the city of Jerusalem survive. And that's the kingdom of Judah. And compared to Egypt or Assyria or Babylon, you know, it's a a minnow these great empires keep coming along kicking sand in the in the face of the kings of judah and so they're constantly trying to you know work out which you know should
而且令人着迷的是，他在巴比伦的口粮配给单都被找到了。所以他在巴比伦受到了尊重的对待。你知道，他和所有的犹大贵族一起被安置在战败国王的收容所里。他们获得了用于三餐的口粮之类的东西。我的意思是，相当丰厚。你知道，他受到了尊重的对待。他的叔叔被扶植为巴比伦的傀儡国王，并被赐名为西底家（Zedekiah）。他回到了耶路撒冷。他回到了耶路撒冷。是的。
we side with the egyptians or the assyrians or the babylonians whatever nebuchadnezzar he he's seen off the assyrians the babylonians have seen off the assyrians they've seen off the Assyrians. The Babylonians have seen off the Assyrians. They've seen off the Egyptians. 597, Jerusalem is conquered. The king gets taken with a whole load of Judean noblemen. This is Jehoiakim. Am I saying that right? That's, and fascinatingly, his kind of ration dockets have been found in Babylon. So he gets treated with honor in Babylon. You know, he gets kind of put in a hostel for defeated kings with all his, you know, all the Judeans. They get given a kind of rations for meals and things. I mean, quite a lot. You know, he's treated honorably.
而在最初这次围城11年后，他犯了一个致命的错误，认为反抗巴比伦人是个好主意。结果证明这是个糟糕透顶的主意，因为巴比伦人攻占了耶路撒冷。他们摧毁了所罗门圣殿——你知道的，那座曾矗立在犹太人生活核心的圣殿。用《列王纪》的话来说，“他们在西底家眼前杀了他的众子，并且剜了西底家的眼睛，用铜链锁着他，带到巴比伦去。”
And his uncle is installed as a kind of Babylonian puppet. And he gets given the name of Zedekiah. And he's back in Jerusalem. He's back in Jerusalem. Yeah. And he makes the fatal mistake 11 years after this initial siege of deciding that it would be a good idea to rebel against the Babylonians. Turns out to be a terrible idea because the Babylonians capture Jerusalem. They destroy Solomon's temple, you know, the temple that had stood at the heart of Judean life. And in the words of the Book of Kings, they slew the sons of Zedekiah before his eyes,
所以，不仅约雅斤和西底家在巴比伦，还有很大一部分——或者也许我夸大了，也许是小部分——犹太人也在那里，因为有一种他们身处流亡之中的感觉，对吧？绝对是的。那么我们谈论的是多少人呢？很难说，但肯定都是些——你知道的，精英阶层。
and they put out the eyes of Zedekiah, and they bound him with fetters of brass, and they carried him to Babylon. Right. So it's not just Jehoiakim and Zedekiah that are in Babylon, but a large proportion, or maybe I'm exaggerating, maybe a small proportion of the Judean people, because there's the sense that they're in exile, right? Absolutely. So what numbers are we talking about? Hard to know, but it's certainly the kind of, you know, it's the elite.
所以是贵族、祭司、文士。你带走的不会是一群农民。他们被——怎么说呢，被投入监狱，还是只是被安置在城市的某个区域，或者别的什么？不，这是美索不达米亚每个人都会做的一件普遍的事情，那就是当他们征服一个民族时，他们会把领袖们带走，并将他们带到首都——嗯，不仅是首都，有些人会被扔到一些区域性的城市里。所以以西结（Ezekiel），他做过著名的“枯骨复活”异象，他就不在巴比伦。但显然有许多犹太人在巴比伦。所以，这会对《圣经》许多书卷的写作产生什么样的影响，是一个非常非常巨大的问题，因为
So it's the nobles, the priests, the scribes. You're not taking a load of peasants. And they've been what, put in prison or just put in no quarter of the city or what no so this is this is a common thing that that everyone in mesopotamia does is that when they conquer a people they will remove you know the kind of the leaders and and take them to the capital um well not not just capital some of them get kind of dumped in in kind of regional cities so ezekiel who famously has the vision of uh the bones coming back to life he's not in babylon but clearly there are a lot of there are a lot of judeans who are in babylon and so the question of what kind of influence does this have on on the writing of um a lot of the books of the bible is a huge huge issue because
其中一些《圣经》书卷——我们正在谈论先知书，对吧？比如以赛亚书（Isaiah）、耶利米书（Jeremiah）等等。它们是在巴比伦写的吗？它们是在从巴比伦返回之后写的吗？所以耶利米是一位曾预言耶路撒冷毁灭的先知。然后他基本上留在了当地——他没有被带到巴比伦。
are some of those books of the bible um we're talking about books of prophecy, aren't we? Like Isaiah, Jeremiah, and so on. Are they written in Babylon? Are they written after they've come back from Babylon? So Jeremiah is a prophet who has foretold the ruin of Jerusalem. And then he remains kind of, he doesn't get taken to Babylon.
他只是四处转悠，说“一切都糟透了”。但在预言了巴比伦将摧毁耶路撒冷之后，他接着说道——而这是关键所在，这也是为什么犹太人可能开始真正成为犹太人的原因。圣殿虽然没了，但他们并没有放弃对他们上帝的信仰。事实上，由于身处巴比伦的经历，他们对上帝的信仰似乎变得更加尖锐，并且变得更加一神论。一些学者认为，或许是因为巴比伦人本身崇拜偶像，这在他们心中激起了对偶像崇拜的一种更强烈的敌意，因为偶像崇拜与巴比伦息息相关。
He just kind of hangs around going, everything's awful. But having prophesied that Babylon will destroy Jerusalem, he then says, and this is the key thing, and this is why perhaps the Judeans start to become Jews. The temple has gone, but they don't give up their belief in their God. And indeed, their belief in their God seems to kind of sharpen and become more monotheistic as a result of the experience of being in Babylon. Perhaps some have said, some scholars argue, because the Babylonians themselves are idols that instills a kind of enhanced sense
汤姆，这完全是两个截然不同的版本。一种说法是，后来成为犹太人的人是在模仿马尔杜克；另一种说法是，他们对巴比伦宗教感到如此反感，以至于他们在做完全不同的事情。是的，我认为后一种可能性大得多，因为对巴比伦的敌意是绝对显而易见的。正是耶利米以最强有力的方式将这种敌意定格下来。所以你引用了《启示录》中的话，《启示录》正是汲取了耶利米对巴比伦毁灭的愿景——他热切期盼这种毁灭的到来。因此，“巴比伦素来是耶和华手中的金杯，使天下沉醉；万国喝了她的酒，就颠狂了。”这正是你在看到对巴比伦的恐惧时所体会到的那种观念。然后是《圣经》中我最喜欢的经文之一——
of hostility towards idol worship because it's associated with Babylon. Those are two totally different versions, Tom. So one is what become the Jews are copying Marduk, and the other is they are so revulsed by Babylonian religion, they're doing something different. Yeah, I think that the latter is much likelier, because the hostility towards Babylon is absolutely palpable. And it's Jeremiah who enshrines it most powerfully. So you quoted from the book of Revelation, the book of Revelation is drawing on Jeremiah's vision of the destruction of Babylon that he hopes will come. So Babylon has been a golden cup in the Lord's hand that made all the earth drunken. The nations have drunken of her wine, therefore the nations are mad. That's exactly the kind of idea that you get with the horror of Babylon. And then one of my favorite verses in the whole of Bible,
由于它与巴比伦有关，因此对偶像崇拜充满了敌意。汤姆，这是完全不同的两个版本。一种说法是后来的犹太人在模仿马尔杜克，另一种说法是他们对巴比伦宗教感到如此反感，以至于他们在做一些不同的事情。是的，我认为后一种可能性大得多，因为对巴比伦的敌意是显而易见的。正是耶利米以最有力的方式将其奉为圭臬。所以你引用了《启示录》，《启示录》借鉴了耶利米对巴比伦毁灭的愿景，他希望这一天会到来。因此，巴比伦曾是主手中的金杯，使全地陶醉。万国都喝了她的酒，所以万国都疯狂了。这正是你对巴比伦的恐惧所产生的那种想法。然后是整本圣经中我最喜欢的经文之一，
Babylon shall become heaps, a dwelling place for dragons, an astonishment and an hissing without an inhabitant. And that is a prophecy that again hangs over Babylon because actually the prophecies turn out to be accurate in the long run. Well, I mean, Babylon's been sacked so often in its history that you could reasonably predict that it would probably be sacked again. But Tom i'm being very very cynical and um apologies to any listeners uh who are displeased by this but you could say that this is a bit like the is this much more than the how should i put it the internet ramblings of somebody who's really embittered about some geopolitical development and they're saying we will get our revenge you know the equivalent of a kind of russian troll saying the West will pay for this or that or whatever.
巴比伦必成为乱堆，为野狗的住处，令人惊骇、喴笑，无人居住。这又是一个笼罩在巴比伦头上的预言，因为事实上，从长远来看，这些预言往往是准确的。我的意思是，巴比伦在其历史上被洗劫过那么多次，你完全可以合理地预测它可能再次被洗劫。但汤姆，我表现得非常非常愤世嫉俗，呃，向任何对此感到不满的听众道歉，呃，但你可能会说，这有点像——这不仅仅是——我该怎么说呢——某个对地缘政治发展怀恨在心的人在互联网上的胡言乱语，他们说我们会报复的，你知道，这就相当于某种俄罗斯网军说西方会为此付出代价之类的。
I mean, because Jeremiah is basically wanting to see visited on Babylon the same thing that has been visited on the kingdom of Judah, right? Absolutely. And the Judeans are simply not, you know, it's not like the Greeks who in the long run will be able to, you know, Alexander will be able to cast his invasion of Persia as revenge for the persians having burned the acropolis in athens the judeans have there's no you know they're too small um to have any prospect of that and most most people in in um you know who who get well like the you know the 10 tribes of israel they just vanish and disappear they get absorbed into the the population of the city that they've been transported to. What's really distinctive about the Judeans is that that doesn't happen. And that the Judeans, although they seem to have been utterly humiliated, the temple of their God has been wiped out. It seems that their
我的意思是，因为耶利米基本上是想看到降临在巴比伦身上的事，也降临在犹大王国身上，对吧？完全正确。而且犹大人根本就不是——你知道，这不像希腊人，从长远来看，亚历山大能够把他的对波斯入侵描绘成对波斯人火烧雅典卫城的报复——犹大人没有，你知道，他们太小了，根本不可能有这种指望，而且大多数人，在呃，你知道的，那些流亡的人，比如以色列的十个支派，他们就这样消失了，被他们被流放到的城市的居民同化了。犹大人真正与众不同的是，这种事并没有发生。而且犹大人，尽管他们似乎受到了彻底的羞辱，他们的上帝的圣殿也被摧毁了。似乎他们的
God has been caught wanting all the kind of the furnishings of the temple in Jerusalem get taken to Babylon. The Judeans do not give up on their God and they do not lose their identity. And if anything, their identity gets sharpened. And that is what's interesting. And it seems to me that their identity is sharpened by, well, you can call them kind of the internet ramblings, but it's a kind of a sense that the only way that they can make sense of the horror of what's happened is to see it as part of the plan of their God, which is a kind of incredibly arrogant thing to do. And they're nobody, they're kind of tiddlers they're the kind of very very small fish yeah but they're saying that they end up saying that ultimately everything that happens to babylon is the expression of the will of their god and so the the stories that you get particularly in the
上帝被证明力不从心，耶路撒冷圣殿里的所有器皿都被带到了巴比伦。但犹大人并没有放弃他们的上帝，也没有失去他们的身份。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是他们的身份变得更加鲜明了。这才是最有趣的地方。在我看来，他们的身份之所以变得鲜明，是因为——嗯，你可以称之为互联网上的胡言乱语，但它是一种感觉，即他们理解所发生之可怕事情的唯一方式，就是将其视为上帝计划的一部分，这是一种极其傲慢的做法。他们什么都不是，他们就像小鱼小虾，那种非常非常小的鱼，对，但他们最终说，最终发生在巴比伦的一切都是他们上帝意志的表现，所以你在
book of daniel are a kind of fascinating distorted mirror held up to that well this is what i wanted to ask about because they have this really fascinating treatment of people like Nebuchadnezzar in the Bible, don't they? Because on the one hand, they see him as a symbol of cruelty and oppression, of tyranny and of kind of power, of all that is evil about power. But at the same time, it's very clear that Nebuchadnezzar is the instrument of God's will, that he has been picked by god to punish the people of judah for their sins isn't he so he's so they're sort of saying you may be very evil but at the same time
《但以郎书》中看到的那些故事，就像是一面奇妙而扭曲的镜子，映照出这一切。这就是我想问的，因为他们在《圣经》中对尼布甲尼撒这样的人有着非常迷人的处理方式，不是吗？因为一方面，他们将他视为残酷与压迫、暴政以及权力的象征，象征着权力邪恶的一切。但与此同时，很明显，尼布甲尼撒是上帝意志的工具，他被上帝选中来惩罚犹大人民的罪孽，不是吗？所以他们有点像在说，你可能非常邪恶，但与此同时
you're actually an instrument of our god's plan so you're just a tool yeah and and also that because of what nebuchadnezzar's done therefore he will be punished and that and and babylon will be punished and they're able to say that because they know what happens which is basically nebuchadnezzar dies you get this this this guy called um nabonidas who is is not of the royal family but seems to have been a very distinguished general he's quite elderly when he becomes king um he's actually the he's the the son of a priestess in the um the syrian city of haran where they worship sin who is a moon god he's very keen on sin but more generally nabonid as we mentioned him in the first episode he's he's a great antiquarian he seems to have decided that that that marduk's promotion to to kind of the rank of top god is um is historically inaccurate
你其实是我们上帝计划的工具，所以你只是一个工具，是的，而且也因为尼布甲尼撒所做的一切，他将受到惩罚，巴比伦也将受到惩罚，他们之所以能这么说，是因为他们知道后来发生了什么，基本上就是尼布甲尼撒死了，然后你有了这个叫拿波尼度（Nabonidus）的家伙，他不是王室成员，但似乎是一位非常杰出的将军，他当国王时年纪已经很大了，他实际上是——叙利亚哈兰城一位女祭司的儿子，他们在那里崇拜辛（Sin），也就是月神，他非常崇拜辛，但更广泛地说，拿波尼度——我们在第一集提到过他——他是一位伟大的古物研究者，他似乎认为马尔杜克（Marduk）被提升为最高神的地位在历史上是不准确的
and so he i mean it's very odd he goes off to to a place in North Arabia, a place called Tamar, and he's there for 10 years. And it's very strange. You know, what is he? What, you know, why is he doing it? Is he doing it because he thinks the gods have ordered it? Is he doing it because he hates Babylon? He doesn't want to have anything to do with it. He can't, you know, he doesn't want anything to do with it he can't you know he doesn't want to have mixed with with marduk means he's doing a kind of akhenaten equivalent um is he going there because um tamer is a strategic center from which he can build a great trading empire in arabia or is he mad and we don't really know but what we do know is that um this makes him very, very unpopular in Babylon, where he has left his son, Belshazzar, as regent. And this is foolish because the Babylonians see the king's obedience to barley is planted, where the king has to go to the temple of Marduk. He has his ears pulled and he's slapped. I can see why you'd want to avoid that. Well, yeah, the Balaamians want that. And then you go in again.
所以他——这真的很奇怪——他去了北阿拉伯的一个地方，一个叫塔马尔（Tamar）的地方，在那里呆了10年。这太奇怪了。你知道，他是什么人？他为什么这么做？他是因为觉得这是神的旨意才这么做的吗？他是因为恨巴比伦才这么做的吗？他不想和它有任何瓜葛。他不能，你知道，他不想和它有任何瓜葛，他不能，你知道，他不想与马尔杜克混在一起，这意味着他在搞一个类似于阿肯那顿（Akhenaten）的把戏吗？他去那里是因为塔马尔是一个战略中心，他可以从那里在阿拉伯建立一个庞大的贸易帝国？还是他疯了？我们其实并不知道，但我们确实知道的是，这让他在巴比伦变得非常非常不受欢迎，他在巴比伦把儿子伯沙撒（Belshazzar）留作摄政王。这很愚蠢，因为巴比伦人认为国王对——种植大麦时，国王必须去马尔杜克神庙。他的耳朵被揪，还挨了耳光。我能理解你为什么想避开这个。好吧，是的，巴比伦人就想这样。然后你再进去。
And if you cry, then that's a great sign because tears show that Marduk is pleased. So you really, you know, you're really getting slapped around. Nabonidus doesn't do this for 10 years and so therefore what's been going on while he's been off in in arabia is that the persians under cyrus the great um have defeated the medes they've defeated the lydians who who rule basically what's now Turkey. So Cyrus is very much the coming man. And Cyrus is a master of propaganda. And he said there's a famous, the Cyrus cylinder, which some people say, this is the first bill of human rights.
如果你哭了，那这就是个大吉兆，因为眼泪表明马尔杜克很高兴。所以你真的，你知道，你真的挨了不少耳光。拿波尼度连续10年都不搞这一套，因此，当他在阿拉伯的时候，发生的事情是，居鲁士大帝（Cyrus the Great）领导下的波斯人击败了米底人，击败了统治基本上现在土耳其地区的吕底亚人。所以居鲁士绝对是正在崛起的新星。而居鲁士是宣传大师。他说，有一块著名的“居鲁士圆柱”，有人说，这是第一份人权宣言。
It's no such thing. It's a very, very Babylonian text in which he's basically saying, I'm going to respect your gods. And this means that in the long run, Nabonidus proves powerless against Cyrus's invasion. Cyrus, because basically there are lots of people in Babylon who are unwilling to fight for him. And the story goes, it's in Herodotus' wonderful story, you know, sense of how vast Babylon is, that the Persians break in and Babylon is so huge that people in
根本不是这么回事。这是一篇非常非常巴比伦风格的文本，他在其中基本上是在说，我将尊重你们的神。这意味着从长远来看，在居鲁士的入侵面前，拿波尼度被证明是无能为力的。居鲁士之所以能得逞，主要是因为巴比伦有很多人不愿意为他战斗。故事是这样的，希罗多德（Herodotus）精彩的故事中提到，你知道，巴比伦是如此巨大，以至于波斯人攻进来时，
the city who are celebrating a party as Babylonians do, don't even realize that they've been conquered. The city is so enormous. So that's the Herodotian take. But, of course, there's the famous biblical take on this story. Tom, let's take a break. Yes, let's do that. Sorry, I'm talking too much. No, no, no.
城里正在像巴比伦人那样举行派对庆祝的人们，甚至都没有意识到自己已经被征服了。这座城市实在是太大了。这就是希罗多德式的看法。但是，当然，关于这个故事，还有一个著名的圣经视角。汤姆，我们休息一下吧。好的，那就这样吧。抱歉，我话太多了。不，不，不。
It's absolutely fascinating stuff. Take a break and we'll come back and we will do the Book of Daniel and the extraordinary story of Belshazzar's Feast and then we will be talking about Babylon and its fall and its afterlife. See you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Babylon.
这绝对是引人入胜的内容。休息一下，我们回来后将讲解《但以郎书》以及伯沙撒盛宴的非凡故事，然后我们再来聊聊巴比伦的陷落及其死后余波。如果您想收听无广告版、独家番外节目并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们正在讨论巴比伦。
Tom, I cut you off because we were just about to talk about probably the single most famous depiction of Babylon ever, which is the Book of Daniel. So everybody knows this. Daniel, well, they don't do that anymore, but they used to. Daniel is invited to a feast with his pals, isn't he? And Belshazzar, who we mentioned before the break, has got all the looted gear from the temple.
汤姆，我刚才打断了你，因为我们正要谈论的可能是巴比伦历史上最著名的一幅画面，那就是《但以郎书》。每个人都知道这个。但以理——好吧，他们现在不这么做了，但过去常常。但以理和他的死党们应邀去参加一场盛宴，对吧？而在休息前我们提到过的伯沙撒，拿走了圣殿里所有掠夺来的装备。
And he says, you know, tuck in. And they don't want anything to do with it. And then these words appear. Well, you can tell the story more. You tell a story in your purple prose, Tom. No, go on. So am I right in thinking that these, I don't know, there's all thunder and lightning or whatever it is,
他说，你知道，开吃吧。而他们压根不想碰。然后这些字就出现了。好吧，你可以把故事讲得更生动点。用你华丽的辞藻讲讲这个故事吧，汤姆。不，你来。所以我是不是可以这样理解，这些，我不知道，有什么电闪雷鸣之类的，
and the words that appear on the wall, these sort of only… Phantom hand. Phantom hand, exactly. And it takes only Daniel can read them, only Daniel can translate them. Is that right? Yes. So this phantom hand appears and writes on
然后墙上出现的文字，这些只有……幻影之手。幻影之手，没错。而且只有但以理能看懂，只有但以理能翻译。是这样吗？是的。所以这只幻影之手出现，在
the wall this is the writing on many many tackle or passion is that right that's right yes and nobody can understand it so daniel translates that many god has numbered thy kingdom and finished it tackle thou weighed in the balances are not found wanting perez by kingdom is divided and given to the medes and the persians and so that's the the famous scene of the fall of Babylon, which has been, so there's a famous painting by Rembrandt of Balthazar looking like a 1980s cricketer gazing in horror at this mysterious hand. But also John Martin in the early 19th century who did vast canvases of huge cities and lightning striking and idols toppling um and and i i think that that is a absolutely fundamental
墙上写下了这些文字：“弥尼，弥尼，提客勒，乌佩法新”（Mane, Mane, Teckel, Upharsin），是这样吗？没错，是的，没有人能看懂，所以但以理翻译说：“弥尼”是神已经数算你国的日子到此为止；“提客勒”是你被称在天平里，显出你的亏欠；“佩勒斯”是你的国分裂，归与米底人和波斯人。这就是巴比伦陷落的著名场景，雷 Rembrandt（伦勃朗）有一幅著名的画作，画中的伯沙撒看起来像个20世纪80年代的板球运动员，惊恐地盯着这只神秘的手。但还有19世纪初的约翰·马丁（John Martin），他绘制了巨大的画布，上面有巨大的城市、闪电和倒塌的神偶像，而且我认为这绝对是
part of the kind of the mystique of babylon is is because of the book of daniel which is written after after babylon has fallen when's the book of daniel written probably so probably third century oh golly a long time after so it's it's it's quite a few centuries after it um and it gives this distorted history so nebuchadnezzar's the guy who sentences daniel to the lions he sentences um shadrach mishak and abengnego uh who are three of daniel's pals to a fiery furnace they both come they all come out of that and survive daniel gets enshrined as um an advisor a kind of dream reader to um to to nebuchadnezzar so he's kind of like the equivalent of joseph and his technicolor dream coat yeah he is to pharaoh um then uh nebuchadnezzar goes mad all right but he didn't go mad though in reality no so this is
巴比伦神秘感的一个极其核心的部分，这正是因为《但以郎书》，它写于巴比伦陷落之后。《但以郎书》是什么时候写的？大概吧，大概是公元前3世纪。哦天哪，那是很久以后了！所以它是在那之后的好几个世纪才写的。它提供了一段被扭曲的历史：尼布甲尼撒是那个把但以理判给狮子的人，他把但以理的三个死党——沙得拉、米煞和亚伯尼歌判进了烈火窑，结果他们都从里面出来了，并且活了下来。但以理被奉为尼布甲尼撒的顾问和解梦人，所以他有点像约瑟及其彩衣梦想的世界版，对吧，对法老来说那样的人；
this is clearly nabonidus so this is this is tradition that nabonidus has gone mad babylonian tradition that is then attributed to Nebuchadnezzar. And again, it's kind of brilliant description. The same hour was the thing fulfilled upon Nebuchadnezzar. He was driven from men and did eat grass as oxen and his body was wet with the dew of heaven till his hairs were grown like eagles feathers and his nails like birds claws. And William Blake did a famous kind of illustration of that. Absolutely brilliant. And then you have this account of the fall of Babylon
然后，尼布甲尼撒疯了。好吧，但在现实中他并没有疯，没有。所以这
where Belshazzar, rather than Abinadus, is described as the last king and it falls and the Medes and the Persians take over. Actually, it's the Persians. And from that point on, Babylon is subject first to the Persians, then to the Greeks. So the Daniel story, just to the Persians, then to the Greeks. So the Daniel story, just to wind that up, the Daniel story, which obviously proved enormously influential because it really enshrined in the kind of Judeo-Christian imagination, the
显然是指拿波尼度，所以这是拿波尼度发疯的传统，后来被归到了尼布甲尼撒头上。同样，这也是一种极其精彩的描写：“当时这话就应验在尼布甲尼撒身上，他被赶出离开世人，吃草如牛，身被天露滴湿，头发长长，好像鹰毛，指甲长长，如同鸟爪。”威廉·布莱克（William Blake）画过一张非常著名的插图。绝对精彩。然后你就会看到关于巴比伦陷落的记载，
image of Babylon as a place of power, of corruption, of hubris, kind of great luxury of the feast and then looming disaster, didn't it? Yeah. But that's written centuries afterwards. And it's just a basically basically very very garbled version of history would you say it's it's holding up a very distorted mirror and a lot of of so daniel's prophet so so uh nebuchadnezzar is the guy who has the dream that bart van loo talked about um oh yeah the idol with the feet of clay yeah um and he has visions of um of beasts coming out of the ocean all these kind of things uh and essentially this is predicting that babylon
其中伯沙撒（而不是拿波尼度）被描述为最后一个国王，巴比伦陷落了，米底人和波斯人接管了权力。实际上是波斯人。从那时起，巴比伦先是受波斯人统治，然后是希腊人。所以但以理的故事——为了做个小结——但以理故事显然产生了巨大的影响，因为它真正将犹太-基督教的想象力中对巴比伦的印象固定了下来：
will fall that the persians will rise then that the greeks will rise um in due course it comes to be seen as uh as as foretelling the rise of rome so this idea of cycle of empires yeah or come on to rome on. Rome and Babylon. Interesting relationship in imagination. And so Daniel is, you know, whoever's writing the book of Daniel is writing in the knowledge, firstly, that the Babylonian Empire has collapsed and that Babylon has been conquered by foreign masters. But also that the city itself is starting to go into decline. And that didn't happen straight away, though. No, it doesn't. But also that the city itself is starting to go into decline. And that didn't happen straight away, though.
一个充满权力、腐败、傲慢的地方，有着盛宴的极度奢华，随之而来的是迫在眉睫的灾难，对吧？是的。但那是几个世纪后写的。这基本上是一个非常非常混乱的历史版本，你会说它高高举起了一面极其扭曲的镜子吗？但以理的许多预言——所以尼布甲尼撒就是那个做过巴特·范·卢（Bartholomeus van der Helst）谈到的那个梦的人，哦，对，那个脚踩泥足的偶像，对，他幻想到有野兽从海里出来，所有这些事情，本质上这就是在预测巴比伦
No, it doesn't. It's absorbed into the Persian Empire and it's still the biggest city on earth at that point. Yeah, there's a rebellion under Xerxes, who's the king who invades Greece. And the Great Ziggurat is very badly damaged. But it's still, you know, unbelievably, it's the largest city still in the world so when alexander enters it it's it's a very alexander place i mean he ends up dying there well i was about to say when he arrives he's greeted by the townsfolk because they see him as a some of them at least seem to have seen him as a pretended to see him as a liberator from persian rule am i right a bit like in egypt yeah i mean of course they're they're
会陷落，波斯会崛起，然后希腊会崛起。随着时间的推移，它后来被视为预示着罗马的崛起。所以这种帝国循环的理念，对吧？我们接着聊罗马。罗马和巴比伦。想象中奇妙的关系。因此但以理——无论谁写《但以郎书》，他在书写时都知道两件事：首先，巴比伦帝国已经崩溃，巴比伦已经被外族统治者征服；其次，这座城市本身也开始走向衰落。不过，这并不是马上就发生的。不，确实没有。但这座城市本身也开始走向衰落。不过，这并不是马上就发生的。
saying that obviously because he's standing there with his with his sword with his yeah and his phalanx i mean yeah of course i mean they're used to that it's it's telling that that's the place that he spends a lot of time at the end of his reign that's the place that he dies yeah because it's not i suppose it's it's it makes sense because it's not persian not quite persian but a bit persian well you think i mean i mean a lot of so a lot of these cities it's it's it's makes sense it's not persian not quite persian but a bit persian well you think i mean i mean a lot of so a lot of these cities it's conquered they they get renamed they get given greek names babylon doesn't yeah babylon is too famous um and alexander clears the the rubble that xerxes left of of the great ziggurat and is preparing to rebuild it and that never actually happens um and what then
不，并没有。它被并入波斯帝国，在那个时候它仍然是地球上最大的城市。是的，在入侵希腊的国王薛西斯（Xerxes）统治期间发生过一次叛乱。大塔庙遭到了非常严重的破坏。但它仍然——难以置信的是——依然是世界上最大的城市，所以当亚历山大进入它时，这是一个非常“亚历山大”的地方，我的意思是，他最后死在那里。嗯，我正要说，当他到达时，他受到了市民的欢迎，因为他们视他为——其中一些人至少似乎视他为——假装视他为摆脱波斯统治的解放者，我没说错吧？有点像在埃及那样。是的，我的意思是，当然，他们这么说
happens is that um all that kind of region of of mesopotamia um becomes part of the selucid empire so one of the heirs of alexander and they never think about establishing their capital at babylon tom well they they they so they build a new capital called mod modestly, Seleucia. On the Tigris. On the Tigris, yes. And there is, so one source says that one of the kings orders Babylon to be emptied and that the people should go to Seleucia. So this is, and people say that this is where basically Babylon starts to collapse as a city. Difficult to know. There are counter traditions. So one of the kings, Antiochus III,
显然是因为他拿着宝剑站在那里，带着他的方阵，我的意思是，是的，当然，我的意思是他们习惯了这一点。很有说明意义的是，这是他在其统治末期花了很多时间的地方，也是他最终死去的地方，对吧？因为这不是——我想这是合乎逻辑的，因为它不是波斯领土——不完全是波斯，但又有点波斯的感觉。你会怎么想——我的意思是，很多这样的城市被征服后，它们会被重新命名，被赋予希腊名字，但巴比伦没有。巴比伦太出名了。亚历山大清理了薛西斯留下的巨大塔庙的废墟，并准备重建它，但这件事最终从未发生。
he actually puts on the robe of Nebuchadnezzar when he's performing the rituals that are required at the Esagila. So the Esagila certainly seems to be functioning right the way up into the Roman period. But basically it is, so Trajan, the Roman emperor at the beginning of the second century, who invades and briefly conquers Mesopotamia, he goes to Babylon and he offers sacrifice to Alexander there in the place where Alexander is said is said to have died so there's clearly still enough of the infrastructure of babylon there for people to work out exactly where everything is
接下来发生的事情是，美索不达米亚的那整个地区成为了塞琉古帝国（Seleucid Empire）的一部分，也就是亚历山大的继承者之一。他们从来没有想过把首都定在巴比伦，汤姆？嗯，他们——他们建立了一个新首都，非常谦逊地命名为 Seleucia（塞琉古）。在底格里斯河上。在底格里斯河上，是的。有这样一个记载，说其中一位国王下令清空巴比伦，让居民去塞琉古。所以这就是——人们说巴比伦作为一座城市就是从这里开始崩溃的。很难说。也有相反的传统。例如，其中一位国王安条克三世（Antiochus III），
but but but by this point it's becoming what jeremiah had foretold it is becoming a dwelling place for dragons and astonishment and then hissing it's been deserted by the time it's starting to become that yeah right yeah and do we know before we start talking about the image of babylon and its kind of cultural afterlife, do we know at what point it basically became an archaeological site? As in, I mean, I don't mean in the 19th century or something. I mean, at what point it was no longer inhabited and it was basically dead?
他在埃萨吉拉（Esagila）神庙执行必要的仪式时，真的穿上了尼布甲尼撒的长袍。所以埃萨吉拉神庙肯定一直运转到罗马时期。但基本上——因此，在公元二世纪初入侵并短暂征服美索不达米亚的罗马皇帝图拉真（Trajan），他去了巴比伦，并在亚历山大据说死去的那个地方向亚历山大献祭。所以显然巴比伦仍然有足够的基础设施，让人能够准确找出所有东西在哪里。
Very difficult to say, but probably, I mean, probably by 1st or 2nd centuries AD. Okay, as early as that. So there's obviously never a possibility of the Arabs, you know, rebuilding it or something. It's mentioned in the Quran as the home of two angels called Harut and Marut who teach sorcery. Right. But that's probably drawing on biblical traditions of Babylon as the great center of sorcery. But that's probably drawing on biblical traditions of Babylon as the great center
但到了这个时候，它正在变成耶利米所预言的那样：它正在成为野狗的住处、惊骇和嘘声之地。在它开始变成那样的时候，它已经被废弃了。对，没错。在我们开始讨论巴比伦的形象及其文化后代之前，我们知道它大概在什么时候基本上变成了一个考古遗址吗？我是说，我不是指19世纪什么的。我是说，它在什么时候不再有人居住，基本上彻底死寂了？
of sorcery. Certainly by the time of the Arab conquest, it's long, long been abandoned. So basically what happens is that as we said before, because it's not built of stone but of clay and mud,
很难说，但可能——大概在公元1st或2nd（一或二）世纪吧。哦，这么早就开始了。所以阿拉伯人显然根本不可能重建它什么的。它在《古兰经》中被提及，是两个名叫哈鲁特（Harut）和马鲁特（Marut）的天使的家园，他们教授巫术。没错。但那可能借鉴了圣经中关于巴比伦作为巫术伟大中心的传统。但那可能借鉴了圣经中关于巴比伦作为巫术伟大中心的传统。
it kind of melts and becomes a kind of sludge. And people do remain settled on what had been one of the royal palaces outside Babylon itself. And that gets called Babel, so right the way up into the modern period. So there is, to that extent, a kind of living continuity. But otherwise, the very site itself gets forgotten. And by time that european archaeologists are turning so actually in the middle ages there are jews who come because they want to see the site and they want to see the site not so much because of nebuchadnezzar but because um lots of jews have stayed in babylonia so even though cyrus allows them to go back and rebuild the temple and live in Jerusalem and everything,
当然，到阿拉伯人征服时，它已经被废弃了漫长漫长的岁月。所以基本上发生的情况是，正如我们之前所说，因为它不是用石头建造的，而是用黏土和泥土建造的，
lots of them do stay in Babylonia and it becomes the great center of Jewish scholarship. So this is where the Talmud comes to be written. And it's known as the Babylonian Talmud, the Talmud that is written in Babylonia. So it's a place that visiting rabbis are very interested in. So we have records of them coming in the Middle Ages and kind of rootling around and trying to work out where places have been. But it's not until the 19th century and European archaeologists that they're really able to start kind of pinning down
它有点像融化了，变成了一种污泥。人们确实继续定居在巴比伦本身之外的某座前皇家宫殿的遗址上。那个地方被称为巴别（Babel），一直延续到现代。所以从这个程度上讲，有一种活生生的连续性。但在其他方面，遗址本身被遗忘了。当欧洲考古学家开始——实际上，在中世纪，有一些犹太人来到这里，因为他们想参观遗址，他们想参观遗址与其说是因为尼布甲尼撒，不如说是因为许多犹太人留在了巴比伦尼亚。所以尽管居鲁士允许他们回去重建圣殿、住在耶路撒冷以及所有这一切，
exactly where the site was. But Babylon lives on, obviously, very vividly in the Western imagination, in the imagination of Christendom. Once you start digging into the whore of Babylon, there's immense fun to be had there because of course, yeah, from Luther onwards, the whore of Babylon was equated with the Catholic church.
但他们中的许多人还是留在了巴比伦尼亚，这里成为了犹太学术的伟大中心。这就是《塔木德》（Talmud）被书写的地方。它被称为《巴比伦塔木德》，即在巴比伦尼亚编写的《塔木德》。所以这是一个让来访的拉比们非常感兴趣的地方。因此我们有他们中世纪来访并四处搜寻、试图弄清楚各个地方在哪里的记录。直到19世纪欧洲考古学家到来，他们才真正能够开始精确锁定遗址的确切位置。
And there's lots of Protestant propaganda showing the whore of Babylon with the kind of papal tiara. The, I think people like the, the Mormons, the seventh day Adventists picked up on this later on and obviously in rastafarianism babylon is equated really with the kind of white the antithesis yeah it's the antithesis of zion it is the it is it is corruption it is power it is european colonization the legacy
但巴比伦显然仍然非常生动地活在西方想象中、基督教世界的想象中。一旦你开始深入探讨巴比伦大淫妇，那里有无穷的乐趣可寻，因为当然，从路德（Luther）开始，巴比伦大淫妇就被等同于天主教会。
of slavery it is the police it's authority it's it's all the sort of man yes the man exactly but that what's so interesting about that is am i right in thinking that reflects at the time of the book of revelation was written that reflects an antipathy to rome in particular that babylon there is rome yeah absolutely yes absolutely um so tell tell me, is that a common metaphor, basically, at the time, do you think, for people to, would people have referred to Babylon as Rome? Yeah, because it's, so St. John is drawing on the language of Jeremiah writing about Babylon. So we had all that stuff about, you know, Jeremiah talks about the Babylon as a golden making um the nations mad with its wine and you have almost word for word in in book of revelation for all nations have drunk of the wine of the wrath of her the whore of babylon her fornication and the kings of the earth have committed fornication with
有很多新教的宣传画，把巴比伦大淫妇描绘成戴着教皇冠冕的形象。我想，摩门教徒、基督复临安息日会等后来也采纳了这一点，显然在拉斯塔法里教（Rastafari）中，巴比伦实际上等同于那种白人的——对立面，是的，它是锡安（Zion）的对立面，它是腐败，它是权力，它是欧洲殖民主义，奴役的遗产，
her and the merchants of the earth are waxed rich through the abundance of her delicacies so babylon at this point is a you know a great pile of mud. This is being written in the aftermath of the destruction of the temple by the Romans. It's written, the year of the four emperors has happened. Rome has been set back on its foundations, but it has looked briefly as though the empire might fall to pieces. The temple of Jupiter in Rome has been burned. So the Romans themselves have lived with a kind of apocalyptic sense that things might fall to pieces. And the book of Revelation is describing a vision of the fall of Rome and Rome as the archetype of power. So it's
它是警察，它是权威，它是所有那种“体制”（the man），是的，体制，完全正确。但关于这一点，最有趣的是——我是不是可以这样理解，这反映了《启示录》撰写时的那个时代，反映了对罗马的某种特殊厌恶，即巴比伦就是罗马，对吧？绝对是的，绝对是，嗯——所以告诉我，在当时，这算是一种常见的隐喻吗？你认为人们会把巴比伦称为罗马吗？是的，因为圣约翰（St. John）借鉴了耶利米关于巴比伦的语言。所以我们有所有那些内容，你知道，耶利米谈到巴比伦是一杯金杯，
everything that we've been talking about in the context of Babylon, that it's obscene sexual practices, it's incredible wealth. So the thing about the merchants, I mean, it's a very, very economically literate piece of writing, the book of Revelation. It absolutely understands that it's trade routes and tribute that feeds Rome, that feeds Babylon, that without these Babylon will be nothing, that it's not self-sustaining. And it describes how it's the object of kind of universal lust and desire that people come from around the world to the city because it is so stupefying and beautiful and amazing and overwhelming and impressive. And that's why it's a whore. It seduces you. And that's why it's a whore. Yeah. It seduces you. And, and that,
使列国喝醉了酒，你在《启示录》中几乎能一字不差地找到：“叫万民喝起邪淫、烈怒之酒的巴比伦大淫妇”，“地上的君王与她行淫”，“地上的客商因她奢华的繁盛发了财”。所以此时的巴比伦是一堆巨大的烂泥。这是在罗马人摧毁圣殿之后写成的。它是写在“四帝之年”（Year of the Four Emperors）发生之后。罗马已经恢复了根基，但曾经短暂地让人觉得这个帝国可能会分崩离析。罗马的朱庇特神庙被烧毁了。所以罗马人自己也带着一种末世感生活，觉得事情可能会四分五裂。而《启示录》描绘了一个关于罗马陷落的幻象，并将罗马视为权力的原型。所以它就是
that's why the chain of connection is Babylon, the Babylon written about by Jeremiah and Daniel. Yeah. Then becomes the, the Babylon that is Rome in the book of revelation. But the power of that idea of the great imperial city that is oppressive, but will fall. You can absolutely see the appeal of that is oppressive but will fall, you can absolutely see the appeal of that to, say, to Rastafarianism. In fact, I would go so far as to say that the anti-imperialism
我们一直在巴比伦语境下谈论的一切：它淫秽的性实践，它难以置信的财富。关于商人的事情——我的意思是，这是一篇经济学素养非常非常高的作品，《启示录》。它完全明白是贸易路线和进贡养活了罗马，养活了巴比伦，没有这些，巴比伦就什么都不是，它无法自给自足。它描述了它是如何成为一种普遍的欲望和渴望的对象，人们从世界各地来到这座城市，因为它如此震撼、美丽、惊人、压倒一切且令人印象深刻。这就是为什么它是一个娼妓。它诱惑你。这就是为什么它是一个娼妓。是的。它诱惑你。而这，
that today people in the West take for granted, the ultimate roots of that lie in the books of Jeremiah and Revelation. I was just thinking, Tom, we did our 9-11 podcast, the attack on New York. The idea of, I mean, isn't that how Islamists might think of New York? A city of great vice, a city of luxury, of power, but it will fall to attack it, to bring down the symbols of power? Yeah. So in the Quran, there's lots of descriptions of great cities. I mean, the Quran does not go in for the naming of geographical places that the Bible does,
这就是为什么连接的链条是：耶利米和但以理笔下的巴比伦，后来变成了《启示录》中作为罗马的巴比伦。但那种伟大的帝国城市——具有压迫性但终将陷落——的想法的力量，你完全能看出它对拉斯塔法里教的吸引力。事实上，我甚至可以说，今天西方人视为理所当然的反帝国主义，其最终根基就在于《耶利米书》和《启示录》。我刚才在想，汤姆，我们做了关于9·11袭击纽约的播客。那种想法——我的意思是，伊斯兰激进分子不就是这样看待纽约的吗？一个充满邪恶的城市，一个奢侈、权力的城市，但它会遭到袭击而陷落，权力的象征会被摧毁？是的。所以在《古兰经》中，有很多对伟大城市的描述。我的意思是，《古兰经》不像《圣经》那样喜欢给地理地点命名，
but it's evident that a lot of these kind of images of cities, it says, that get destroyed by God and fall is drawing on that kind of biblical imagery. And as I said, Babylon itself gets named in the Quran. But I think in the West specifically, the idea of the anti-imperial, the idea that imperial capitals must fall and this is good, it's inconceivable without that biblical inheritance. But I mean, Rastafarianism is consciously rooted in it but also tom that image that you so often see you see in blockbuster films you see it in all kinds of sort of um cultural products that seems to me drawn directly from belshazzar's feast i mean you've seen it a thousand times in films without thinking about it of the of the the
但很显然，许多关于这些城市的形象——它说，被上帝毁灭并陷落的城市——都是在借鉴那种圣经意象。正如我所说，《古兰经》中确实直接提到了巴比伦。但我认为在西方，特别是反帝国的观念、认为帝国首都必须陷落且这是件好事的观念，如果没有这种圣经传承是不可想象的。但我的意思是，拉斯塔法里教是有意识地植根于此的，而且还有汤姆，你在大片中经常看到的那个形象，你在各种各样的文化产品中都能看到，在我看来，那直接取材于伯沙撒的盛宴——我的意思是你在电影里看过一千次而没有去多想，那就是将电影镜头剪辑到富有和名流们在某个派对上享受，而末日（毁灭）降临在他们身上，有点像哥谭市陷落那种感觉。嗯，这非常具有——这非常符合《但以郎书》，不是吗？
cutting between the film the the the footage of the the rich and famous at some party enjoying a nemesis you know being upon them as sort of the fall of gotham city kind of thing well that's very about that's very book of daniel isn't it well so it's griffiths isn't it i mean intolerance that we we talked about in the 1922 yeah episode that i mean he literally rebuilds babylon yes i mean he goes out into the desert and rebuilds it yeah but for that and and um you know actually saddam hussein does as well so saddam hussein kind of tries to rebuild babylon and yeah we had a couple of questions about saddam hussein actually you know to what extent do do the legends of babylon how much are they part of iraqi identity today are they part of iraqi? I'm not massively convinced they are, but maybe I'm wrong.
那是格里菲斯（D.W. Griffith）的风格，对吧？我的意思是，我们在1922年的那一集里谈到过的《党同伐异》（Intolerance），他简直是重建了巴比伦，是的，我的意思是，他走到沙漠里去把它重建了，是的。但不仅如此，呃，你知道，萨达姆·侯赛因（Saddam Hussein）也这么做了。所以萨达姆·侯赛因有点试图重建巴比伦，是的，我们实际上收到过几个关于萨达姆·侯赛因的问题，你知道，巴比伦的传说在多大程度上构成了今天伊拉克身份认同的一部分？它们是伊拉克身份的一部分吗？我不是很确信它们是，但也许我错了。
Well, no, they are. So they were promoted by Saddam in his more secular stage because Babylon is something that all Iraqis can feel a sense of identity with. So Sunni and Shia and Christians and Yazidis and Jews and everybody can kind of have a sense of it in the past. And there's an obvious kind of model for a Mesopotamian, you know, an Iraqi strongman in the figure of Nebuchadnezzar. So when Saddam, you know, kind of did his rebuilding of Babylon,
不，它们是的。它们是萨达姆在世俗化阶段大力宣传的，因为巴比伦是所有伊拉克人都能产生身份认同感的事物。所以逊尼派、什叶派、基督徒、雅兹迪人、犹太人和所有人都能在某种程度上在过去找到这种认同。在美索不达米亚——一个伊拉克强人的形象中，尼布甲尼撒就是一个显而易见的榜样。所以当萨达姆重建巴比伦时，
because there's nothing really to see in Babylon. People turn up and there's, you know, a load of dust. That's me with all archaeological sites. So Saddam wanteddam wanted you know to provide something that was slightly more impressive and so a lot of the kind of the mud bricks are stamped you know just as nebuchadnezzar had had his name stamped on the mud bricks saddam does exactly the same um and and one of the reasons why the islamic state when they then move into northern iraq why they demolished the Assyrian monuments is because they want to get rid of anything that provides Iraqis with a reminder of the pre-Islamic past. So for the Islamic State and for a lot of devout Muslims, national identity is false. It's a distraction from the identity you should have as a Muslim.
因为巴比伦真的没什么可看的——人们到那儿去，只有一堆尘土。我对所有考古遗址都这样。所以萨达姆想要提供一些稍微更有震撼力的东西，于是许多泥砖上都印上了印记——就像当年尼布甲尼撒把他的名字印在泥砖上一样，萨达姆也做了完全相同的事。而且，当伊斯兰国（ISIS）随后进入伊拉克北部时，他们摧毁亚述古迹的原因之一，就是为了铲除任何能给伊拉克人带来前伊斯兰过去回忆的东西。对于伊斯兰国和许多虔诚的穆斯林来说，民族认同是虚假的。它分散了你作为穆斯林本该具有的认同感。
And particularly an identification with a past that is babylonian is kind of shocking yeah um so that's kind of what's going on i mean of course the the americans um they also played their part in in in a further destruction of the further fall of babylon because having um after the iraq war having occupied iraq they then built a huge tank park on the site of Babylon. I mean, the heart of the archaeological site. And so the remains of the Great Processional Way that joined the Ishtar Gate to the Great Ziggurat, they were kind of driving heavy vehicles down it.
特别是对巴比伦过去的认同，可以说是令人震惊的。所以这就是正在发生的事情。当然，美国人在伊拉克战争后占领伊拉克时，也在巴比伦的遗址上修建了一个巨大的坦克停车场，这也加剧了巴比伦的破坏和陷落。我的意思是，在考古遗址的核心地带。所以连接伊施塔尔门（Ishtar Gate）和大塔庙的伟大游行大道的遗迹，就这样被他们开着重型车辆碾压过去。
It's all, you know, all the mud things have cracked. I mean, it's unbelievable. Think of all those buried cuneiform tablets, Tom, crushed under the wheels of the... There's a terrible metaphor there, isn't there? Yeah, so Babylon has fallen again. Think of all those buried cuneiform tablets, Tom, crushed under the wheels of the... There's a terrible metaphor there, isn't there? Yeah, so Babylon has fallen again. Well, do you know what?
这全都是——你知道，所有泥砖结构都裂开了。我的意思是，这太难以置信了。想想所有那些埋藏的楔形文字泥板，汤姆，被……的轮子压碎了。这其中有一个可怕的隐喻，不是吗？是的，所以巴比伦又一次陷落了。想想所有那些埋藏的楔形文字泥板，汤姆，被……的轮子压碎了。这其中有一个可怕的隐喻，不是吗？是的，所以巴比伦又一次陷落了。好吧，你知道吗？
When I was a student in Oxford in the 90s, there used to be... I used to walk by the library. There was graffiti on the wall, Babylon must fall. But that was obviously reflecting the Rastafarianism and the reggae. Because obviously Bob Marley, the kind of reggae, has preserved the image of Babylon as hubristic, corrupt, luxurious, oppressive. At a time when, you know, knowledge of the Bible among the public at large is probably less than any point since, you know, the Christianization of the Roman Empire.
当我90年代在牛津做学生时，曾经有——我过去常常走过图书馆。墙上有涂鸦写着“巴比伦必须陷落”。但这显然反映了拉斯塔法里教和雷鬼音乐的影响。因为显然鲍勃·马力（Bob Marley）、那种雷鬼音乐，将巴比伦的形象保存为傲慢、腐败、奢侈、压迫的代名词。而在那个时候，你知道，公众对《圣经》的了解可能比自罗马帝国基督教化以来的任何时候都要少。
Yes, I think that's absolutely true. Which raises our last question, Tom, because I think you've done an absolutely masterful job and i know you've carried well i was about to say 80 but it's probably about 98 of the load of these podcasts so tom he dave walters asks i'll cut his question down he asks very simply where did bony m rank in the pantheon of historians well the um so it comes so by the rivers of babylon um it comes from one of the psalms yeah uh and it describes the um the exiles weeping uh you know the rivers i guess it's the canals and the euphrates um and i think i think that idea that there is a kind of dignity in exile is, you know, a dignity in defeat has been culturally incredibly, incredibly important. Ever since, you know, I mean, in a way, the greatest victory over Babylon is that Babylon is now dust and the bible is still red yeah and there is a manifestation there of the kind of the core biblical teaching that you know the future isn't always with the
是的，我认为这绝对是真的。这就引出了我们的最后一个问题，汤姆，因为我认为你做了一项绝对精湛的工作，而且我知道你承担了——我本来想说80%，但可能大约是这档播客98%的工作量——所以汤姆，戴夫·沃尔特斯（Dave Walters）问了一个问题，我把他的问题精简了一下，他非常简单地问：波尼M合唱团（Boney M）在历史学家万神殿中排名第几？好吧，那个——所以“坐在巴比伦的河边”（By the Rivers of Babylon），它出自《圣经》中的一篇诗篇，描述了流亡者在河边哭泣——我猜那是运河和幼发拉底河——而且我认为，那种流亡中有一种尊严、失败中有一种尊严的想法，在文化上是极其极其重要的。自从——你知道，从某种意义上说，对巴比伦最大的胜利是巴比伦现在化为尘土，而《圣经》依然在被阅读。这里体现了一种核心的圣经教导，即未来并不总是属于强者的，也许弱者终将战胜强者。但波尼M的歌里没有引用的是，这篇诗篇的最后一句，那是整部《圣经》中最让人毛骨悚然的一句。你看：将要被毁灭的巴比伦城啊，报复你像你待我们的，那人便为有福！你知道，你们摧毁了我们的圣经——你的圣殿将被摧毁，是的。然后这篇诗篇的最后一句：“拿你的婴孩摔在磐石上的，那人便为有福！”所以你可以看出为什么波尼M没有把那句歌词放进去，你也能明白为什么在教堂礼拜等场合中会有某种克制而不去包含它，直到今天。但我的意思是——但我觉得这节经文——也许比任何其他经文都更能带你回到那种利害关系中，回到6世纪巴比伦统治世界的令人恐惧的本质中——那个世界是如此可怕，
strong that perhaps the weak will will overcome it but what there isn't in in the boney M song, it doesn't quote what is the final line of that psalm, which is one of the most terrifying in the whole of the Bible. So you have, O daughter of Babylon, who art to be destroyed, happy shall he be that rewardeth thee as thou hast served us know you you have destroyed our temples your temples will be destroyed yes and then the very last line of that psalm happy shall he be that taketh and dasheth thy little ones against the stones so you can kind of see why bony m didn't put that line well you can also see it doesn't i mean certain reticence and including it in church services and so on to this day um but but i mean but but i think that you know that that that that verse perhaps more than any other really takes you back to the to the to just what was at stake i mean just the terrifying quality
同时它又是迷人的、美丽的、惊艳的。而那种幻想至今仍萦绕在人们的想象中。但那种掠夺性的特质也是如此令人恐惧。好吧。这是一个完美的结束语。汤姆，我们下周会有一些非常精彩的“掠夺性特质”，因为下周我们将讨论东方的维京人。
of the of the world that you know sixth century babylon was ruling it was one that was so frightening um and it's it's glamorous and it's beautiful and it's stunning. And the fantasy of it haunts the imaginings to this day. But that predatory quality is also so frightening. Well, okay. That's a perfect note on which to end. Tom, we've got some great predatory quality coming up next week because next week we will be talking about the Vikings in the East.
当然，还有俄罗斯和乌克兰国家的建立。所以这是一个非常热门的话题。我们还将讨论走私。汤姆将展示一些非常出色的走私犯声音。所以压力不大，汤姆。我们下周再见，我们两人向大家告别。再见。再见。
Of course, the foundation of the states of Russia and Ukraine. So a very topical subject. And we'll also be talking about smuggling. And Tom will be doing some excellent smuggling voices. So no pressure, Tom. We will see you all next week from both of us. Goodbye. Goodbye.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家番外、抢先收听、无广告版收听以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，
Thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目和抢先购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。